qué
bien
la ciudad de nueva york quiere que la
caída de la bola de times square sea
perfecta por ello muchos asistieron al
ensayo bajo el cómic 19 las grandes
reuniones pueden ser peligrosas así que
para muchos los repasos como este son la
única oportunidad de ver tradiciones
festivas
mi propósito para el próximo año
definitiva definitivamente intentaré
salir de donde estoy y definitivamente
espero volver aquí el próximo año verdad
cuál es tu propósito para el próximo año
espero conseguir un montón de cometas
nueva york- ha mantenido las
festividades pero la gente tendrá que
usar mascarillas y solo los vacunados
podrán asistir en londres el 'big ben'
sonará 12 veces después de un silencio
de cinco años debido a los trabajos de
restauración pero el tradicional
concierto de año nuevo y los fuegos
artificiales se cancelaron en río de
janeiro los fuegos artificiales están de
vuelta incluidos los de la playa de
copacabana aunque otras festividades
habituales no sucederán brasil fue uno
de los países más afectados por la
pandemia pero las cifras de contagios
han bajado durante las últimas semanas
trayendo de vuelta a los turistas y la
gente es consciente de llevar su
mascarilla lamentablemente no llevo la
mía ahora por supuesto aquí la atención
a grecia pero creo que están haciendo un
gran trabajo en lo que respecta a
prevenir la propagación no me parece que
esté tan mal aquí fryer
las autoridades de ciudades de todo el
mundo están tratando de encontrar el
equilibrio adecuado entre permitir que
las personas y las empresas disfruten de
la víspera de año nuevo sin dejar de ser
cautelosos para que la pandemia no se
propague